I think her insistence that the personal
is political was a defense against her
own fear of chaos hi I'm Nick Gillespie
with Reason TV today we're talking with
Ann C Heller author of ein Rand in the
world she made newly out in paperback
damn thanks for talking to us glad to be
here what drew you to writing a you know
a phenomenal well-received biography of
ein Rand I read Ayn Rand not in my teens
or 20s but in my 40s and I had
underestimated her when I began to read
her work I found that she was riveting
in her ability to capture unfamiliar to
me ideas in a plot that just rocked
along no this is the the knock on Rand
is that yeah she's a lousy stylist her
plots are cartoonish so what is it
what's what's gripping about that and is
it the ideas that really drive the the
appeal of the books or it or is it the
melodrama combination of both I'm sure
it's a combination of both and melodrama
by itself is almost unbearable probably
but infused with the ideas as tightly as
it is it's a fantastic vehicle for
delivering her her message in her view
of the world what's the core of her
appeal to to people who pick up her
books now I think the core of her appeal
is her deep love for freedom her
insistence on what are really very
old-fashioned American values of hard
work application of your skills and
earning your way through the world now
at the same time she also made was
insistent that the personal is the
political in a way that certainly
anticipated what the feminist movement
was saying which she was not a fan of
what how does her personal life fit into
her larger kind of worldview as you
played out in the biography I think that
her insistence that the person was
political to use your phrase him grew on
her as she got older when she was
younger she was much
free-spirited and she didn't she wanted
people to understand what she had to say
and if possible to be persuaded by what
she had to say but she certainly wasn't
monitoring people's taste in music or in
literature or in theater or in politics
as she was later what was the most
surprising thing that you found out
about her the most surprising thing to
me was how fearful human beings she was
what did what do you mean by that all
her friends talked about her double
walking doors and you know putting on
heavy rubber gloves to wash ditches so
that she wouldn't be contaminated by
germs and double-checking everything
once or twice but that didn't interest
me very much what interested me was the
fear that she had of her world cracking
at a certain point I think her
insistence that the personal is
political that is that that her
worldview was the only one that could be
adopted by people who are right minded
was a defense against her own fear of
chaos and of all the forces that were at
work to undermine you know the
individual autonomy and where is that
intensity or that of that fear coming
from in her life the first time I
thought about this was when I heard an
old archived interview with a copy
editor of Random House who worked with
Rand for months and months on Atlas
Shrugged and she said to the interviewer
I think Iran was the most fearful person
I ever encountered and when I began to
think about that and look back to her
childhood and her young adulthood I
couldn't help but think how tentative
everything in her life was she was as a
even before the Russian Revolution which
happened when she was 12 years old she
was a Jew in a intensely anti-semitic
society where people could come knocking
at the door at any moment and her
father's business was at the mercy of
the Czar's policemen they could shut it
down they could throw them out of st.
Petersburg none of that happened I
no what did happen to her as a Jew in
st. Petersburg I can't believe that
nothing did she never talked about it
and but I think that was a very fear
making situation for a very sensitive
very intelligent very proud little girl
and then when the Russian Revolution
took place everything was overthrown and
then she shows up in an America that is
also rapidly I mean not as dangerously
perhaps but it is rapidly transforming
and innovating itself that's true and
was also very anti-semitic I think she
loved the changes that she saw going on
in America until the 1930s when she saw
that said a surprisingly large section
of Americans were interested in
communism as a good thing so how do you
how do you measure the kind of legacy
and the continuing relevance of Rand as
a writer as a cultural figure as a
thinker she sells hundreds of thousands
of copies of books how do you sum up her
continuing relevance into this 21st
century she said very early in her
career that fiction is a way to
transport ideas with infused with
emotion
how many novelists have ideas do we have
in the second half of the 20th century
and her ideas were seem to be countered
countercultural at the time this
emphasis on individualism when we were
all talking about what America should do
for the world she is the most accessible
and one of the clearest explainers of
the virtues of capitalism that that
there is I want to thank and how her
author of eine ranted the world she made
newly out in paperback for a great
biography of an R and as well as a nice
conversation Thank You Anne
thank you